when women cheat people say that it
hurts more they sell you this dream take
you down the stream and kind of just
leave you there if you let someone into
your home that's slightly more personal
than you going into someone's home and
women from a practical standpoint they
are allowing you access to their insides
yeah you're just visiting men we are
programmed to want to multiply but it's
like not it's not a choice we wake up
every morning with a full sack and we're
ready to go because women in general
like men that cheat have you ever been
cheated on and have you ever cheated
um yes I've been cheated on and I never
cheat you never how did you find out he
cheated
uh
painful
well I find out
I don't know it's just like sometimes
God loves me too much and they just show
me little things you're right got it God
brought you cheating
hey just happened and I knew he was
cheating because I think men when they
are cheating they they're away
they feel guilty and then try to make it
up to you
uh so he was he was like buying new
stuff and treating you well yeah out of
nowhere okay and so then how would you
get evidence or well I just I'm not a
person that go into someone's phone okay
so far but yeah but it just it just
happened for me to see okay you saw like
a message yeah and I I saw a message and
then from there obviously I checked and
yeah and then like it was him like
messaging yeah come over or something uh
no it was small
I can't really say it say it because
it's a bit inappropriate so oh it was
like some sexual stuff okay I feel like
we've got a qualified question what do
you mean by cheating as in going the
whole way or what's cheating is such a
loser that's a good that's a good
question when I think of cheating I
think of like stuff
that's like sexual you know I would say
kissing someone else is cheating unless
you're in like in a Range it's not
cheating if you guys agree to that you
know what if it's like a just a flirty
text message yeah like text messages
Instagram that you replied to something
yeah but from there it's starting right
necessarily not necessarily because for
me there's also emotional cheating like
if you invest your emotion emotional
energy in someone else that's also
cheating because I could be with a guy
and then I'm invest in my emotional
energy into another guy I think that
emotional cheating that's that's a woman
thing I think you know like just to be
honest yeah it's a man isn't it see men
men when it comes to men men cheat for
different reasons from when women cheat
you understand what I mean yeah that's
why when women cheat people say that it
hurts more it hurts the man more you
know what I mean because men it's like
our penises kind of talk foreign
certain times you know and once you've
bust that knot
you're like you you snap back to normal
I still love her though yeah yeah after
you bust that not you're like oh you
can't do what am I doing here yeah you
come to understand you come to your
sense of your senses no pun into it so
that's why you're saying man do it just
to go bust it and then after that it
comes in now
guys can have sex without emotions but
with females different they need
emotions very much different yeah men
can can have full-blown sex with a woman
and feel less than a woman sending a
flirty text message exactly like we can
be more upset over them sending a text
message yeah than us having full blown
sex with the world my mum yeah Mama
broke it down from a practical
standpoint right this is genius if you
let someone into your home that's
slightly more personal than you going
into someone's home and women from a
practical standpoint they are allowing
you access to their insides yeah you're
just visiting you can visit 100 houses
in a day not that I recommend you do
that I don't do that by the way
you do it
that's it I'm trying to there's some
study I'm trying to find it that like
backs up what you guys are saying where
they asked like married men that cheated
if they still love their wives and it
was like 85 or 85 80 roughly still said
they did I mean it's not they they don't
they don't love them anymore it's like
maybe they want to try something
different maybe bro so true
yeah
any mom says
that you just said the married men I
remember being a lifter I went to go
clubbing with the guys who was in the um
lift and we see an older guy I must have
been around about say about 65 years old
and he was like oh that's you're gonna
enjoy like have a good night tonight was
that yeah then it was like yeah I'm on a
prom looking for for a woman tonight and
we're like okay because I'm married by
the way but I'm I'm bored he was like
she don't do nothing before me I love my
wife a friend of mine one side behind
every great looking and woman is a man
sick of shagna and I'm sorry to like
because I know women don't want to hear
that but like and it's not all true like
obviously there's exceptions there's all
good there's good guys out there but I
do feel like men we are programmed to
want to multiply that it's like not it's
not a choice we wake up every morning
with a full sack and we're ready to go
and unfortunately for women if you're
not there like that's why women
unfortunately have to be on the A-game
for it's not fair but it's just the way
it is yeah I expect to differ on that
one for the simple facts of you can be
that woman for that man absolutely you
could be everything that he dreams of I
agree and yet still somehow some way I
can be submissive I can give it to you
as and when you want it multiple times
at the day but the truth is if you want
to go out and do that you're going to do
that works both ways no no and I was
gonna get to that so
um you know
to me it's like I've always looked at
cheating I've been on the receiving end
of that and I've been there multiple
times
now it does two things it makes you look
inside yourself and think okay have I
done something in order to
not satisfy him what drove him to look
at me but you're telling me that you
love me you care for me oh you know
you're my world okay show me that I'm
your world but then you still show me
that but then you still feel all right
I'm gonna go out and demand him
yeah different area code they ain't
gonna know no it's not about that do you
know something I'm saying it's the same
with women as well women I believe if
you feel that you have to get to that
point where you're cheating
why are you still in that relationship
why haven't you sat down and had that A
and B okay well I could flip it on human
too why did you choose the wrong man
multiple times in a row then okay no no
disrespect no no and I that's the fact
because there are good guys that is a
very
interesting every man
no I said every man has the urge in them
they're programmed to want to [__] every
day that's well generally I'll answer
because women in general like men that
cheat
is true I mean
my girlfriend
like it's not like a good thing that
makes women look good but look at who
women pick like more two women have
always reproduced for every one man and
while there have been there have been
monogamy like throughout the last two
million years there have been monogamous
societies
um and the majority like of the
population has been monogamous but the
top 15 percent of men
um have never been monogamous ever and
now what's the difference today women
now are completely in control of sex
which has never happened in all of
history right and what has happened
since we've gotten in control of sex we
have been sleeping with a smaller and
smaller percentage of men so what does
that mean we could have the monogamous
guys but none of us pick them so and we
don't when we have the most Youth and
the most Beauty because usually like we
do go into monogamous relationships but
we do it in our 30s because the average
age of first marriage isn't 31 so that
means we're non-monogamous in our 20s I
have a question for the ladies if this
is okay have any of you ever knowingly
like deep deep down inside doing a booty
call knowingly I'm sorry have you ever
been have you ever knowingly been a
booty call like a guy who's just yours
you're a side piece you're not serious
but you're turning up and you know he's
calling you at 11 o'clock for good
reason like he ain't taking you out he
ain't doing all the nice things you're
turning up knowing what this is really
about he may be lovely to you he may say
all the nice things to you but you deep
down in your I'm just I know I'm just
gonna say no no I haven't okay I
personally haven't been in that
situation
um for each people or persons or people
that are in that setup yes what about
situationship anyone raise your hand
situationship never whatever you every
guy you've slept with you've been in a
relationship with 100 years plus okay
okay wow yeah yeah yeah
no of every person arrived okay fine
I've been with you these recruiters need
to stop their game up they're too nice
you see what he's saying though because
a situationship is the same thing no I
understand that is why you are both
single yeah and if you both agree it's
like if you know what the setup is and
you're like okay look I've got a niche I
need you to scratch I'll call you if
that's the setup then fair enough each
of their own but personally I've never
been in that situation were you married
you're married am I you're married
there is a ring there okay yes no it
just surprises me because if you're
still single at 35 I'm like every guy
you're in a relationship by 35. I
wouldn't say every guy that I've been
with I would say in my younger days
um you know when you're finding yourself
and you don't really
women sometimes want a little bit more
than men and
what I wanted is not necessarily what he
wanted but they sell you this dream take
you down the stream and kind of just
leave you there trying to think you know
and that was my experience right but but
that's still a situationship if you
weren't together no we was in a
relationship you were in a relationship
yes we were in a relationship and then
he then went on to go and find
what was appealing to himself and that's
how that relationship dissolved on you
yes I I've never gone out I've never
cheated on an individual but I have had
it happen to me twice
I'm not picking the wrong guides because
it doesn't matter if you're you could be
a really good guy I mean like what one
of you said where you know they went out
and this guy was married but he was
still out there looking for something
else do you know what I mean so
sometimes you can't really how how tall
were the guys how tall
um
oh oh
I don't know I'm like five two so
they're a little bit I don't know
probably six okay six foot and like how
much money did they make roughly well at
the time we were like teenagers so we
were all just grafting we arrived some
of us were either still in college or
you know doing a little Saturday job and
stuff like that we wasn't in a state
where
as I am now in my 30s where I'm more
established so give and take you know we
were still in college
degree or they were in college so they
got a degree too yes so they will yeah
they were working I have I have a point
I'm just gonna I'm just going to read
I'm just gonna read some stats once once
a man earns over 300K um the odds of him
cheating increased by roughly 50 with a
third of men um in that in that higher
income bracket cheating on their wives
only six percent of these Unfaithful men
report that their marriages were coming
to an Ender didn't love their wives
anymore not the remaining 94 still love
their wives goes without saying that men
don't cheat more
um or women don't cheat more when
they're in a higher income bracket
Beyond wealth the men who are over six
foot tall are statistically 38 more
likely to cheat which is presumably just
down to the opportunity
intriguingly um
University degrees are 34 more likely to
cheat okay so it's like if we're going
after the guys with all of these
qualities like do you think we should
maybe expect it on some level
if a guy's over six foot kind of thing
he he believes he's got more power if
you're making more money then that
female you know you got more power
I feel like all of these external things
right they only draw out what is
innately in you already yeah you can be
a millionaire and seven foot five but if
you have morals and principles and you
genuinely love the woman so if you
you're not going to go it's just
nowadays bro there's so much options
oh there's all these other cigarettes
I'll tell you why because if you if you
look at like NBA players like and
professional athletes there are women
that go to those games and seek those
men out trying to get them to cheat on
their wives like there are girls that
have said word for word I I it took me
years but I finally got him to cheat
yeah so so my point is even a good guy
if you're telling me some of the most
beautiful women you've ever seen in your
life are chasing you down hunting you
they know everything about you trying to
get you to cheat I I think like people
are human over the course of like a
20-year career not once yeah but if your
relationship is solely based around a
sexual experience then if of course
there's always going to be someone with
more curvaceous booty just around the
corner but if you're dealing with an
actual woman on a spiritual Financial
Physical Realm then there is nothing
that you're going to give me that this
woman doesn't satisfy me with already
and I'm talking from experience I'll be
honest before any of my ex-girlfriends
call me out in the comment sections I
Was a Serial cheater when I was young
but I've seen firsthand my eldest sister
my youngest sister what they've gone
through and the Heartbreak that a man
was able to cause and it was almost
God's way of showing me this is what
you're doing to these other women
I can tell you the categories yeah
I'm sorry
can I just ask you a quick question
what's the longest you've been
monogamous to a girl five years five
years okay but that's not 25 in the last
in the last four years in the last three
and a half years
in the last three and a half years yeah
I've never ever ever cheated it's never
even crossed my mind and because of my
line of work I can go on my Instagram
right now and I've got blue ticks with
two three million followers ask me to go
to the Estates to have sexual
intercourse and I say no why because
from a mature standpoint I know that
what I want in a woman isn't just sex
you know look at your mother
it's so much deeper than sex yeah I'm
saying like that that happens but I'm
just saying like I think that even a
good man can do it on a bad day that's a
good point like it's not that it's not
that you're purely not if you're in love
no that's it Martin Luther King didn't
you know he had a stable hole bro
Muhammad Ali was out here every other
day with a different world one thing I
want to say is that um when you talk
about these high Achievers these men who
earn over 300 000. those men they they
don't like that doesn't just happen
overnight you have to train your brain
into being a mogul and all of this like
you'd be selfish every single day I
think me me me me so any woman who wants
to then weave in with that wave of way
of life you can't just come up here and
expect an amount to change who he is and
be a different person because he needs
you to weave into his life and a lot of
women aren't willing to do that these
days you know and also part of the
problem is these men are like the alpha
males and I know that's actually like a
ridiculous word to use these days
because people have used it and
bastardize it but I feel like these men
like they're bred to be as successful as
possible to provide and also part of the
problem is they all want to like [__]
every day and they like they're not in
control of themselves around women in
the way that a man who well actually I
wonder a lot of these men who aren't in
that situation are well like slagging
these men off if they were in that
situation would you have these morals
that you claim to have when no one's
trying to [__] you I don't know I just
think cheating is wrong man like even
though I've done it before I've done it
before there's nothing cool about it
should not be glamorized we should not
normalize it we're not I'm not I'm not
saying to glamorize but I'm saying the
last two million years the world has
been one way I'm not going to tell the
world how to be and I think a lot of
times women go into relationships with
like delusional no expectations like the
top 15 percent of men for the last two
million years have always cheated and
now you're coming in and saying well
he's going to be faithful to me okay
good luck my message to women is conduct
yourself in a certain State yeah and if
a man is cheaper than nothing to cheat
and you he's going to lose out and he
will potentially go with a woman who's
going to cheat on him don't don't change
his status and I think that sounds
really nice but it's not nice when they
can't replace the guy and that's the sad
thing is like I'll talk to girls and
they'll talk about how they're mommed or
their mom left their dad because he
cheated and now she's dying alone and so
it's like is it is it really a better
option and that's what they don't talk
I'd rather be alone so you'll be happy
staying with someone that's consistently
cheating on you then that's okay
what does that look like dying alone
okay most women you need 2.5 million to
retire okay and and there's a lot of
evidence to suggest that the UK is going
to start rolling back the benefits that
mostly women are on so what does that
look like dying alone I don't know on
the streets being homeless could you
work it out with your husband not every
woman that isn't in a relationship is
alone they might have a family they
could have kids it doesn't necessarily
mean they alone just because now you
have to moot off of everyone around you
instead of working it out with your
husband I would rather do that I mean I
mean I would rather do that I look at it
like this if you if you've left your
husband you have to understand and you
have to take a board the damage that was
caused now if I was married and I've
I've
brought forth 10 children for you and I
feel that we've built our Empire and
we've got our you know our tribe when
we're good we're strong and then
I was your world and you was my world
and then we had our children you have to
sit down and think well why is she alone
because the damage sometimes is in
reversible irreversible it doesn't
matter how many times you go and you sit
down and you talk to somebody and you're
like well this is what's happened well
have you tried this sometimes that's not
enough so yeah but who has to suffer in
this situations the kids no no and I was
going to get there and you know at the
same time the damage can be unreversible
so that's why they tend to be alone and
yes you're right it is the children that
do end up suffering because you know
they've grown up thinking oh mommy and
daddy is in love and you know they're
always together no no no no no no no I'm
just speaking on this you know and then
it turns out that that may not be the
situation now I know quite a lot of
people that you know you grow in a
household you hear an argument
parents do it all the time they think oh
the children are in bed they're sleeping
but actually no we're here and
everything and it does affect the
children I've worked with children and
I've seen the damage that it's caused
yeah but the effects of a single mother
home are worse and every stat will tell
you you're more likely to commit suicide
you're more likely to me yeah that's
almost the 80 of the prison population
like every real problem in society is
literally linked to a single mother home
and so and so my thing is like I just
think once you have a family it's not
about you anymore it's about your kids
and so it's like this you know this idea
that we can't work through cheating I
just think it's silly you know it's all
about honesty I reckon you know honesty
is I think honestly like cheating
wouldn't be a thing if it was for the
honesty side of things you know I mean
depending on what you're looking for see
like in in 2023 now yeah
um even myself I've been involved in a
throttle yeah it's only for a couple of
weeks
well I've got two girlfriends and my
girlfriends are girlfriends well not
currently it's not the situation
that's a throuple you know what I mean
and um
yeah but it's just a case of honesty you
know what I mean so I was honest with
them they were honest with me no one got
hurt how the [__] did you pull that off
seriously
it's like 23 of women are actually open
to that we're only six percent of men
are I think it can happen if you like
you said honest and open I think it can
well I mean how many women like do like
we all we all know a lot of women who
have no idea they're being cheated on
but like yeah like every guy is going
back to his girlfriend being like yeah
he's cheating like a lot of women out
there just have no idea they're being
cheated on so like maybe they would be
happier if they were just at least
honest about it and the man was like oh
this is around
I promise you I've experienced it myself
I promise you exactly what goes around
if I'm disagreement I've seen a lot of
nice people get [__] over and a lot of
[__] get great like yeah but but you
haven't read the end of the chapter you
haven't read that yeah have they died
there's life there's an opportunity for
karma to be inflicted I'm telling you if
you are a man who breaks people's hearts
and you boast about it and you're proud
and you look in the mirror and you feel
more of a man then there's something
there's something wrong put it this way
right guys let's ask this question get
straight to the chase your mom gets
cheated on how do you feel yeah you'd
feel bad you'd feel bad you feel bad
about something that's normal no I'm
it's normally Society however a majority
of people cheat so it's normal now no no
I said throughout history the top 15
percent of men have always cheated women
cheat more than men nowadays yeah yeah
but yeah regardless of the statistics
and where they sway it's a wrong thing
it's a wrong thing wrong you know what
it is the side of cheating which is
wrong is the emotional damage which is
provides to the other person that's
that's what we um fail every time around
you know I mean so when you're in a
relationship with a person that you love
like for instance I've been in a
relationship a long-term relationship I
cheated on misses you know what I mean
and to me personally it was nothing to
do with
um whether I love her or not you know
what I mean I just found out in later
life that I like different types of
varieties of Pom-Pom that's just how I
roll you know what I mean so but at the
same time that doesn't mean that I
didn't love my girlfriend
I definitely agree yeah no for real you
can still love your girl but it's just
the excitement of another female it's
just the excitement and you're not ready
to be in a room no no but you can be you
can still love that female you're still
going back to that girl you're still
wanting to take her up you're still
waiting
that's basically what you're saying is
as a woman if you want to get in a
relationship we have to expect the men
to cheat on us
foreign
you're saying like the top like 15 to 20
men cheat right so I feel like as women
we do need to take the more responsible
role of choosing better men because we
have that 80 whole percent of men that
don't but my thing is a better man means
and I've learned that like for the last
actual couple of months only recently
and I've learned that and that's big
from watching your shows actually and
it's opened my mind a lot because it's
just like we have a whole 80 percent we
don't want to generalize men because not
everyone cheats right well and when you
think about it so like women used to
select for resources right more more so
than looks because when because we like
we didn't work and usually you would
live at your dad's house and then you
would go to your husband until about the
20s when women started to go to work so
what happened is when that when women
started being the like selectors of
mates our first choice um is looks in
our 20s
and so but what percent of men do we
find attractive only 20 what if 80 of
that is ugly so back in the day the dad
would like like say oh no he's gonna
cheat on you stay away from that boy and
then he would like pick the provider guy
maybe we need to be with an ugly guy
30s they'll switch because it's like
they need a kid times running out um and
so they'll switch from um selecting for
looks to selecting for more provider
first but it's like if you did that in
the beginning but this is the thing
though these these men we're sitting
here going right the top 20 cheap why do
they cheat because they can you tell me
the other 80 if they had it on the table
they wouldn't do the men or just men you
know like us labeling these 20 is all
sold just because they have the height
the resources it could be agree that old
men cheat them no I I think there's
there's definitely exception to the rule
like and like I think me and my guy over
here have a similar story
you know unfortunately like we have this
thing where we're very immature and we
mature later on in life as men I agree
so yeah we we go through this period
where like let's be real you want to
experience yeah we want to try
everything on the menu you know we don't
want to be sitting 50 year old wondering
what was what would that have been like
we want to know and actually you kind of
have to get that out your system before
you go you know what this is actually
childish and one woman who looks after
you has got your back and really cares
about you is the real deal but you're
not going to come to that when you're in
your childish state of mind so yeah we
have to go through that and
unfortunately some of you girls are
victims during that period and that's
yeah it's collateral but yeah I think
like women like we should note we're
getting ourselves into like if you go
for the guy that's rich he's got money
he's tall like you know it's a it's a
strong possibility he's gonna do that so
what are you gonna do if he does don't
have a kid and then cry cheating later
if you know that's going to be a
possibility because girls are going
Central London for instance they're
looking for the guy with the lambo
they're looking for guys with a Mercedes
they want a guy with this this these big
chains I've seen it all the time
but like that's what girls that's what
girls are intrigued too
we tell women like you can have
everything you can be tall you can have
money he can be good looking and he's
gonna be monogamous
but don't just don't cry over this guy
yeah the girls you girls um like
his faithful as their options but are
women really any different like let's
let's say you meet two guys at the same
time one guy's sweet and lovely and the
other guy has all of these things you're
you are gonna also be a bit more drawn
like to this guy who's the provider the
the alpha I'm not sure well accessible
this day and age I think I feel like you
know years ago it wasn't so much
accessible well judging by Instagram and
the way women post anything that is like
like outside in restaurants before where
a woman has literally had a guy taking
pictures of her eating her [__]
dinner for 15 [__] minutes wondering
why is she taking a picture in this
restaurant because she wants everyone to
know what restaurant she's in and he's
the one paying for it and he's getting
laid-based off of that so let's act like
women don't value this because it's
literally all over London everywhere but
what sort of when we keep using this
term sorry it's really irate I mean
women what what a real woman doesn't do
that my mom would never in a million
years go to another club and take a
picture and be like hey real woman
it's what's happening
okay can you can we make a general
consensus that the women in their 20s
today are diff are of a Different Cloth
than the women let's say in their 50s
today yeah yeah
the women in their 50s are more
traditional than the women in their 20s
who like who openly say to me like oh
yeah he's got a girlfriend or he's got a
wife and they're happily ready to break
a happy home I don't condone in that no
I don't condone no I think it's wrong
again there's all the emotional damage
yeah you know I mean and I I put myself
in a category of um I'm like an honest
[__] boy that's why does that make sense
you know what I mean I'm an honor at
least you're honest yeah and um you know
when I'm honest about my my Marine Corps
and whatnot other women tend to be more
attracted to the situation you know what
I mean they tend to they tend to be more
attractive they first of all they go
away a little bit hurt and whatnot like
oh Dave you shouldn't have done that but
then they come back after a while and be
you know they're reasonable you know
they okay you do get a little bit of
Pom-Pom over there that's no problem you
were honest about it and then yeah it
just seems more appealing for some
reason
like that yeah why not just be out here
probably and sleeping with a new girl
every other day I've done that before
but at least you're not hurting
so you need to tell me that all of these
girls who you are sleeping with not one
of them had ideas above what you had
because if I know women and I'd like the
thing I do I'm like my man I keep it
straight darling I'm a single but they
think they can change it they don't they
don't they're not gonna listen they're
going to be like I'm gonna be the
exception yes I agree with you bro but
then the onus is on them I go to sleep
with the clean conscious knowing that
I've not promised anyone
relationship is commitment right okay
I'm confused
let's go you're cool with me talking
about your your job yeah 100 okay okay
so how are you commit like how are you
Faithful if you're on only fans
precisely why I said I haven't been a
relationship for as long as I've done
only fans Oh I thought you said you've
been in it for five years oh I missed I
misunderstood you were saying you're
still in that guess what I have had many
propositions from female content
creators beautiful stunning head to toe
and I've said no because I know I'm not
capable of you know seeing my misses
having sex having whatever sexual
intercourse with some other guy so I
know so I'm not in the business of
harming people and I know that some
girls have said to me it's fine I don't
mind seeing you of other um so you're 32
now and you've been on only fans two
years for two years and then you had the
five-year relationship before that uh
prior to it yeah so the day I created
only fans she left bro I was just I'm
just confused because I thought you said
you cheated before I have when I was
younger 16 17 18 every single day every
day I stopped I stopped the rate the day
I realized that there's nothing so it's
just a little bit like you're confusing
me because in the end you did cheat on
her in a way okay you started the only
fans I'll break it down I'll break it
down okay right when I was young and
naive yeah and I was ignorant I cheated
because I thought it was cool it was a
good thing to do right
then I lost my job only fans presented
itself I had a conversation with my
fiance at the time and I said this is
what I'm going to do whether you support
me you either support me and we stay and
I'll do solo stuff or you walk away and
that's fine I respect it and I will do
collaborations she decided to walk away
I did it it changed my life I retired my
mom I have zero regrets but I will never
no matter how many people and how normal
it is glamorize cheating it's disgusting
I've seen it firsthand what it does to
my family this girl's agreed to marry
you that's a big deal a girl agreeing to
marry you and you turn around and go hey
by the way I'm gonna [__] girls on any
fans no no no no no no no
but I said I was going to do only fans
only fans does not constitute having sex
with other people it could be solo stuff
okay like I put on my Instagram it could
be feed stuff so let's not go down there
right but it's but it's still like
something she didn't agree to in the
beginning great so which is which I'm
not and she left no I know but my point
is it's a little bit like hypocritical
of you to go around saying oh I don't
cheat like that's a horrible thing to do
when it's like kind of did the same
thing there
can I say it again let's reverse this
reverse let's reverse this reverse this
let's go on Instagram yeah right okay
are you a cheater if you've got an
Instagram profile
I think girls are in a relationship yeah
people aren't paying for Instagram they
have a wank over you yeah I don't think
it depends what I know they get it for
free they get it for free but I mean if
I'm in a relationship with a girl and
she's like I'm going on only fans I know
what people are going to pay for so I'm
gonna and if I've proposed to him we're
gonna get married I don't care if you're
working with other people people are
going to be wanking off to you that's
going to bother me so yeah but we had a
conversation if I did it behind her back
on a low-key yeah and I was like right
I'm going to change my Alias they're
going to use a different social media
account so she doesn't find out then I'm
a cheater I'm a real man because I sat
down I said babe this is what I want to
do and this is how I want to incorporate
you into my future my Five-Year Plan and
had she said she would have benefited
from the millions 100 but at least he
was honest with her honestly there is
nothing glamorous about cheese
I'm telling you respect though and this
is from an ex serial cheater my exes
will tell you in the comment section
all right
yeah yeah I've seen do you know what
final thing sorry I'm I'm taking the mic
here if I hadn't seen my sister break
down I thought I was going to lose her
like she was suicidal if God works in
mysterious ways that's why I said karma
is a [__] when I saw that my own two
eyes I said I'll never do this son of a
girl right never so if I want to keep
sleeping with Tom I've done with Jesus
then I would do that but the day I
commit to a girl that's it I'm staying
and the day I don't want to I have an
open conversation babe you're not for me
anymore do you ever think a girl's gonna
review doing the content that you do
guess what I don't care
I don't care my mom is retired and I've
got a lot of money on my bank all about
that obviously it's a situation where
obviously we come to a stage in life
where we all want to settle down and
just have that do it perfect well a lot
of people do you want to be a lot of 16
and be alone uh would I be alone I have
two wonderful nieces that I provide for
them I pay for private school I have my
sister who loves me no no I understand
unconditional I understand that family
is different but obviously certain
people want lacker you come to terms
with with the fact that you your career
May land you alone later on
okay okay I'll tell you right the two
years that I deprived myself from any
social interaction with the two years I
was able to retire my mom and make more
money in 24 months than I made in 30
years socializing with women my
priorities as a human being here is to
provide for my family that's it I've got
you the phobia the luxury of having a
woman in future they're great but if I
don't have answers who cares no no but I
said are you but but in later on in life
not bringing no depression to the show
but my mom recently passed but what I've
done is
um make sure I saw that house for make
sure I don't know this stuff for but
obviously the affection that she can
give me is not always a fiction I have a
a female genuine female but the right
woman come along
with the actual genuine females
no it's not that you're going to
struggle but obviously no you're a
decent looking guy bro do you know what
I mean so it's a thing where like I know
girls are gonna attract you but when
they see things online and if they're
showing up if they're ignorant enough to
base me up on my boss yeah yeah and how
I made my money then that's a reflection
of your ignorance and you don't deserve
to be in my presence are you saying you
would stop it for the right girl a
hundred billion well then I think
bro yeah
really so you think it's a reflection of
them if they judge you for being an only
fan yeah
because to me it's like your morals and
your values and like what you put out
into the world you know what I mean like
it's not to me it's not a positive thing
okay cool that's to you right okay
can we all agree on the fact that if you
were born in a single parent family and
your mom was raised in a council estate
and you used to work in Tesco and you
retired her is that an admirable thing
forget how you got the money is that an
admirable thing yes or no
listen I graduated from King's College
University with a 2-1 right
it's a it's a Russell group University
to get there you need straight A's right
I'm academically savvy I'm a good
brother I'm an awesome son I'm a great
uncle I'm a wonderful multi-faceted
human being if someone is ignorant
enough to judge me in all my existence
based on something as insignificant as
how I make my money then that's a
reflection of you living in the dinosaur
era because it shows that you can be
bought and that's the thing it's like
when you have morals principles and
values like there's some things you
can't be paid to do and it's not not
fast yeah you're not trying to be rude
but I don't think you could say wait
wait wait wait so I I'm saying like I
don't think you can say oh I can make
any decision I want and then and anyone
that judges me it's on them like that
doesn't make sense no trust me you can
see like it doesn't matter how good you
are as a person bro if you miss his nose
you're out there clapping cheeks
but I'm just saying bro
there's more open women that can't
handle that that's not a reflection of
another female of because
you know I know many people that were in
your same situation and and they went on
but they just didn't take like to me
that's kind of a cheat code it's like a
shortcut like I you know my dad he he
was on the south side of Chicago he was
one of 13 kids on a fireman's salary it
wasn't like he grew up rich and he ended
up employing 200 people in like a
company you know and so it's like some
people are in your exact situation they
don't take the easy way out my only
problem with that is is the phrase the
easy way and trust me every content
creator is going to come to my defensive
I used to be and you can Google check me
an English teacher fully qualified I
went to University GTP the whole lot
then I was a managing director in the
city so I can tell you I've done the
social norms and running a successful
only fans account is 10. listen to 10
times harder than being a fully
qualified English teacher
so when I hear phrases like you talk
it's not an easy way okay but it's
easier than okay so it's easier than
it's only selling sex is easier than not
selling sex sex is the easiest sell um
if I wanted to make more money I could
take off my clothes tomorrow and I would
make more money questions and I know
it's harder for a guy so it's not
necessarily the same guy versus girl but
I'm assuming you have women in your
content right okay sex sells yeah it's a
question do you think everyone can jump
on only fans and make millions if it's
that easy if it's an easy one no no I'm
not saying that every single person can
make a ton of money I'm saying it's
easier than not doing it because if if
there was an easier for way if there was
an easier way for you to make millions
you would have did it but when you say
easy don't you think it's difficult
having to deal with like people's
perceptions of you family judgment
social I mean I think isn't that
difficult that's the trade-off for easy
money
but it's not easy if it comes with all
those complications is it it's like
saying instead of drugs easy saying it's
easier than the other option because
otherwise you wouldn't have did it no
problem we can agree to disagree on this
point you don't have to be in Union and
everything we say you have your point I
have mine I I disagree on that front
that's it simple
um who else has been cheated